[Music]
hey
everybody here we are again for another
matinee it's our halloween week matinee
show
talking about halloween movies all
[ __ ] week long god damn it
yeah we're arguing about the guy that
was in them dune
and the guy who was in the the scarecrow
move
i thought it was the same guy and i'm
sitting there going it's like we're
recording the [ __ ] and i'm just kind of
like i'm pretty sure that's not the same
guy but it's like you can't
i thought the dude that played baron
baron harkonnen was the same guy
who played the cop out of salem's lot
and i thought it was the same guy that
played
um the dude from cat's eye
and then i thought it was the same dude
from [ __ ] that scarecrow movie that
we saw but those are two different guys
those are two different guys
well the guy that was in dune and the
guy that was in
cat's eye are the same yeah dude yeah
but the dude that was in darkness
scarecrow is not the same that's not him
that is a different
okay but there's it's like it's it's a
type
yeah it's like there was always those
kind of type of like tv and movie actors
like in the 70s and 80s that always
played like these kind of gruff
no-nonsense
donut eating cops and [ __ ] like that he
always played like that kind of part
yeah um so i can see where you there was
a lot of that type of
guy like a lot of that type of character
actor going on at that time now the guy
who played
baron harcone and and the guy who played
the cop
from salem's lot i think is the same guy
no see i don't remember i'd have to look
that up again because i don't remember
i only vaguely remember who played the
cop and then now i'm like confused
because you get me like thinking about
all this
okay so anyway so we're talking about
again
badger says it's the same guy from dune
in salem's lot
okay but it's not the same guy that was
in darkness scarecrow yeah dark knight
the scarecrow is not that same guy but i
thought it was that same guy yeah guy
who played the mailman
yeah okay yeah all right
i got it straight whatever i don't know
i just i just i just missed that guy he
looks like that same guy
they do like i said they look very
similar but uh but it's yeah you know
how white people are they all look alike
they do kind of yeah well i mean certain
types of stuff yeah certain types of
they do
but um that's true all right so as i
said uh
this week since it's halloween week
we're gonna be talking about like some
newer kind of halloween adjacent movies
so on this one we're actually going to
be talking about a
an anthology film from 2013 called
all hallows eve now this movie
is notable because it was the first
feature-length
appearance of the later iconic character
art the clown uh who actually probably
he probably got most famous when
terrifier came out because i think
terrafire came out in what
2015 2016 something like that so
i feel like that movie like when it hit
netflix
because we watched it uh with shawna and
eric were over here and we like had a
[ __ ] great time watching that because
it was like super gory and everything
but what i didn't realize when i saw
terrifier
was that art the clown had been
introduced prior
in like some in some short films and
then was in this anthology film
so okay so what happened with this movie
basically the dude um who wrote directed
edited
did the make of special effects makeup
and everything for it he's like a
renaissance man
uh his name is damian leone i think i'm
pronouncing that right
and he had actually made a short film
called the ninth circle
and then he also made another film in
2011
that was a short film called terrifier
which is not the same as the
full-length terrifier that they made
later on so are we with me so far okay
so when he decided that he was gonna
make like a full-length movie because so
many people responded so well to art the
clown because he's
like pretty [ __ ] scary um
so he decided to take those two short
films
shoot a new film and then make it all
an anthology and film like a wrap around
you see what i'm saying yeah
which came out in 2013 and was called
all hallows eve
now i will admit i watched this again
for the review i saw this
actually for the first time last
halloween night because i was looking
for halloween adjacent movies that were
on tubey
which this one is for free the sequel is
also on there too and i'll talk about
that a little bit too because i watched
that this morning
but so this is basically three
different stories that were shot at
three different times
on like three different kinds of film uh
with art the clown looking kind of
different in every single one because i
guess like i said there were several
years
between it that said um it's not a bad
little flick i mean honestly
i think that the wrap around and the
third story
are the best ones i think so yeah like
the the first two
okay now i'm gonna say right here like i
did like this movie but that middle
uh story you know the one with the alien
that was dumb as hell but um the first
one
and the first one was okay it was kind
of cheesy like the costumes were kind of
cheesy
but that one was the oldest i think he
shot that one in like 2008
and um so so it looked like a different
quality
and like the costuming and stuff was not
really that good it kind of looked like
some
you know spirit halloween like masks or
something like that a little bit
but it did have art the clown in it
looking a little bit different like he
wasn't as scary as he became later on
yeah
it's the best part it's the best part of
the movie though well i think that
people really like responded to that
character
um the terrifier movie the full
full-length movie blows this out of the
water though
oh definitely yeah you want to see that
first and then if you really like that
you can go back and watch where
you know what i mean the prototype the
origin the origin story
but you know it's enjoyable but like i
said
that second that sec that last one is
the best one
that's got the clown in it it's a good
story yeah and it's not long
you know yeah i mean the whole movie is
only like an hour and a half so
basically
i now i do like that because um
he was using like two short films he had
already shot like years prior
um he came up with like a pretty a
fairly uh
clever way to incorporate it all into an
anthology
what he did with the wraparound story
was the wraparound is it's halloween
night there's a babysitter
who i the first time i saw this movie i
thought is that that [ __ ]
actress that was on the [ __ ] that
played pam on the office god it looks
just like her
but then i looked it up and it's not
it's an actress named katie mcguire
who's a new york actress and i guess
she's been like a whole bunch of other
[ __ ] too but she looked
in this movie particularly she looked
like she was like the spitting image of
[ __ ] pam from the office so like the
whole time i was distracted
but um so she's like a babysitter she's
babysitting these two kids on halloween
night
and the boy has gotten
a an unmarked videotape in his
treat bag and can't remember who put it
in there so
now i i will say that even though this
is supposed to be set like
it was contemporary with it was supposed
to be set in 2013 like if we had cell
phones and [ __ ] like that
it's very weird to me that if you got
like a random vhs tape in your trick or
treat thing
in 2013 they'd be like hey we happen to
have a vcr
yeah yeah it's hard i don't have one i
didn't i haven't had a vcr
for at least 15 years if not longer
you'd have to get it out of the goddamn
attic and set it up
that's what i mean it wouldn't just be
like attached to the tv already yeah and
then you'd have to have
you'd have to have the right splitters
and everything to get it to go into the
av
[ __ ] connection i mean unless you're
james from cinemassacre
who has like a massive vhs collection
and he has every single player that's
ever been made he has a betamax he has a
[ __ ]
laserdisc player he has like all that
[ __ ] unless you're like a collector i
don't see why anyone in 2013 would have
a vcr
like just ready to play movies on if you
had if you took my blue
blu-ray collection and turned that into
vhs it would take up
them an entire room of the house those
things were huge people don't realize
that
yeah some of these guys that do these
shows like you said like cinemaska
that have all that stuff the set that
they work off looks like
looks like a video right now because
that's what you need
like i think that's his whole entire
basement yeah has he has made it look
like a video store
like the exact same size he's got all
the shelving and everything yeah and
that's what you would need
yeah because they're giant but like i
said i can see if you're like a
collector i will mention
i'll talk about this in a bit because i
did like i was curious i was curious
so i watched the um the sequel like
earlier this morning just while i was
doing other [ __ ] i just put it on the
background
and i will say that the sequel did
address this
briefly like i guess because i guess
people would criticize like who the [ __ ]
out of vcr in
2013 that was like hooked up and ready
to the tv but whatever it's like you
know what i'm not it's a movie that's
what i mean it's just a movie
so basically the kids are all like oh we
want to watch it even though the first
thing you would think is like it's got
to be porn right it's like that's
the first thing i would think so the
babysitter is like okay well we can't
watch it it's like
you know we'll watch a little bit of it
and if it like looks scary or if it
looks like porn if we see somebody's
testicles or something then we
you guys have to go to bed and you can't
watch it anymore so they start watching
it and
obviously it turns out it's a horror
movie and so it turns out that
the three like shorts are portrayed as
[ __ ] that's on this videotape that the
babysitter is watching
so what they do like as the as the
shorts play out every every now and then
they'll like cut back to
the babysitter like drinking wine on the
couch or like the little kid like
watching it going oh
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] up it's like that
kind of [ __ ] and then like so they
so they go through all the shorts and
then like at the end
if spoiler alert um they imply that art
the clown who has kind of been
he's in most of the segments he's in the
alien one but only as a painting
which i thought was very strange but
i'll get into that in a minute
um but at the end of the movie it's kind
of like
he's gonna like bust out of the tv and
like come into the real world type of
thing
so i kind of like the way they did that
but
like i said so the first segment is
basically
um his short film the damian leone's
short film the night circle
which is just this girl she's in a train
station at night supposedly halloween
night this doesn't have a real
i mean other than the wrap around which
is obviously halloween night like the
house is decorated like how you know
they're going to carve a pumpkin blah
blah
um but the rest of them are not really
that halloweeny you know what i mean
like the first one
kind of you know there's a couple people
in costume like in the train station
like that are drunk and they're like
going home from a party
but it's like other than that like this
shorts aren't really like halloween
themed but the wrap around is
somebody in the comments section is
asking what a vcr is
that's what i mean i had to explain to
them what a vcr is
yeah that's what yeah fourth row down
said would a kid have known what a vhs
tape was in 2013.
i'm not entirely sure and i watched um i
really i there's another really good
horror channel called dr wolfila
and um he did a review of this although
it wasn't well it was him but in one of
his other incarnations
it's a long story um but he reviewed
this and he said the same thing he's
like would a kid even know what a what a
vhs tape was
yeah if he was like he was supposed to
be like 10 or 12 or something like that
in 2013
when you've been like what the [ __ ] is
this thing i know i could hand a kid a
[ __ ] eight-track tape and they
wouldn't know what the [ __ ] that was
well yeah i barely know what i barely
know what that because that was like i
mean that was when i was a little little
kid yeah i remember that
they're like that big and you put it in
like by the time i was buying stuff it
was just regular cassette tapes yeah
you know what i mean like eight my dad
had some eight tracks but even then it
was like starting to
like yeah but so yeah but that was one
thing i did wonder about
so the first one there's just a girl on
a train station um art the clown shows
up
and starts like honking his horn at her
that that's not a
innuendo and um basically like ends up
taking her down
into this into these tunnels and i guess
there's like a satanic cult or some [ __ ]
down there so she gets like
some woman gets a baby cut out of her
stomach and this is pretty gory and i
mean like the gore effects
are really well done the makeup in the
first and second
shorts um not so great like
they're just very costumey but the gore
especially in the third segment is
actually like really really well done
i think i mean for for obviously like
what a low budget they had yeah i mean
it's damn near a homemade movie
it is and it looks really good though
it's fun to watch it does that
yeah it's like like i said it's that
it's a little uneven
um just be and you can tell that it was
shot at like wildly different times but
it's you know that said it does hold
together and i think that i mean art the
clown that character
you can tell why he became like such a
cult sensation i mean [ __ ] they've got
like mugs
with him on it like [ __ ] action
figures and [ __ ] like that i think the
cool thing about art the clown
and i think what damian leone said about
doing this character
he's like i wanted to do like a scary
clown but
like the opposite of pennywise because
pennywise had like a personality
and he was like kind of looked like a
regular clown but he was like funny and
[ __ ] like that
he's like i just wanted a clown that was
like creepy and didn't talk
yeah so i think that's kind of what
makes him creepier
also like the first dude that played him
like in this i don't think it's the same
guy that played him in like um
in the full-length one but i think the
the way that he moves like his body
language and stuff like that like makes
him a lot creepier as well
um so he's pretty creepy in this
although i think he's scarier and
terrifier
like i said terrifier is a better movie
i mean it is yeah and i mean
i mean terrifier like i said we had that
was remember that after it was late
afternoon and i think shawna and eric
came over
i was laughing and we were drinking and
it was like so gory and everything we
were just having a [ __ ] blast
i did too that's kind of that said on
holiday too i hadn't seen a real good
kind of like gory horror movie in a long
time i saw that and i was just that
yeah didn't somebody get like cut in
half like long i always liked when that
happened it was always because i don't
know why i like that gag
everything about it was over the top you
know it was over the top so you know it
had a lot to me i thought it was
humorous
yeah which [ __ ] trip you get a little
bit of that
in this because basically like i said
the first one is kind of more like a
satanic cult thing
it's not super gory and like some of the
devil makeup is like okay but it's just
kind of like costumey looking
the second story like i said doesn't
have anything to do with art the clown
it's basically like this girl or this
woman
and she's just moved to this new house
out in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere her
husband's not home i don't know where
he's at she's talking to her friend
or is she talking to her friend on the
phone or her husband on the phone or
something
she's talking to somebody on the phone
something looks like it lands in the
backyard and then like the rest of the
segment is basically an alien like
stalking her through her house now
initially i think that they wanted the
alien
to be a puppet or like you know
a large puppet but i guess they couldn't
do that so it's just like a dude in a
costume and it's very clearly a dude in
a costume
so i do feel like even though like the
costume is cool looking
um it's really not that scary plus i
think they show it too much
and then i feel like they're just kind
of like well we need to have art the
clown in this one too because we're
trying to make like an anthology movie
so it turns out apropos of nothing
that this woman's husband is a painter
and he's like oh i
did this painting it was this face and i
don't even remember painting it like i
just woke up and it was then she pulls
the
cloth off at the end and of course it's
like aren't the clown's face it's a good
it's a cool painting
but art the clown doesn't have anything
to do with the alien so i don't know but
it could have done without that second
segment probably but then the third one
is actually i think the best one and the
third one is actually the closest
to terrifier you know what i mean yeah
because i think
this one might have been the short film
that was called terrifier
and then when they made terrifiers
full-length movie they just kind of like
expanded out
so because it feels like it has the same
tone and i each and i actually even kind
of like
the third one that they made it look
like
i mean it's very obviously made it look
like an old film
it has like old fem film filter on it
yeah like you can tell
but i like that look to it though they
look good you know what i mean
so it's basically like i mean all the
stories are pretty much the same it's
always like a woman and she's getting
stalked by either art the clown or
um or an alien or a guy in an alien
costume
but um so that's basically what happens
in this one it's like a girl she's like
[ __ ]
on a road trip stops to get gas and uh
you know she goes
the the guy at the gas station is like
helping her out he's like kicks aren't
the clown out because apparently art the
clown is like smeared [ __ ] all over the
walls in the bathroom and he's not
having it
um and then later she goes into the gas
station and sees that art the clown is
cutting this dude into pieces and what
is a very good effect
and then it's kind of like you know a
big chase at the end and it has like a
really gory ending
and then like i said you go back to the
wrap around and
art has kind of like come into the real
world with the babysitter and all that
other kind of stuff
we'll say um i like that they went there
and spoiler alert killed the kids
yeah that's right yeah it was a good
scene they went there
they did it's a so i feel like you're
this is obviously somebody that's like
really really
into slasher movies and really into gore
and stuff like that and you can tell
that it was
even though the the first movie all
hallows eve is like a little bit uneven
um it's still like a fun watch i would
recommend probably if you're gonna watch
an art the clown movie i would recommend
watching terrifier first
and if you liked that then maybe go back
and watch all hallows eve
yeah fort drawer down says he's saying
it'd be awesome to have an amc pacer
and an eight-track player somebody out
there has got to have one
yeah i think i think the pacer is now a
collector's item which boy that's
incredible to believe that that car is
worth something same with the gremlin i
think is where is worth something
that amc pacer had one i remember
hearing that that amc pacer had nearly
200 pounds of glass in it
wow really yeah that that back glass
window i think was like nearly like 70
pounds just the back window on it but uh
it's a lot of [ __ ] glass people don't
realize how much glass weighs and
it was thick 70s glass so you don't want
to be like
going through that [ __ ] windshield i
think it was nearly 200
pounds of glass if i remember correctly
it was just like splattering yeah
ridiculous but yeah so like i said if
you want to see an art the clown movie i
would recommend watching terrifier first
which i think is
it might be on to be i think it's on
netflix yeah um
but and then if you like that then maybe
you want to go back and see this one is
like his origin story
i think they're doing another movie with
him and i think they're also doing a
comic book
because like i said he kind of struck a
chord this character because he's creepy
you know and the guy that plays him is
like really good like and everything
now just um as i said out of curiosity i
noticed that all hallows eve 2
was also on to be so this morning while
i was doing something else i said why
not so i just kind of put it on my other
laptop and had it kind of going in the
thing and i kept like glancing over at
it now the interesting thing about all
hallows eve two
is that it doesn't have anything to do
with art the clown it is an anthology
movie
uh it's nine shorts some of which are
very short like some of them are only
like three minutes or something like
that
um so yeah it's nine different shorts
it's i think it's nine different
directors
um so i think that damien leone maybe
had something to do with putting it
together but i don't know if he directed
any of the segments i think it's like
all different people
that said it's actually it's weird
because
it's probably a better it is a better
maid movie
than the first one um and it's a more
cohesive movie than the first one even
though it was made by nine different
directors
but it's weird that they called it all
hallows eve two because it doesn't have
anything to do with the first one
like there's no art the clown there's no
anything it's like it has a similar wrap
around
in the sense that there's like a woman
drinking wine on a couch like the
babysitter in the first one
and she's just like um you know she
finds a videotape on her doorstep
and i love that in the second one she
has an excuse because she's talking to
her friend on the phone also
and she's like hey some weirdo like left
because it wasn't art the clown it was
like the spirit of halloween or so
somebody like in a pumpkin mask or
something
um and she's like yeah somebody left a
vhs on my doorstep
and the friend is like you have a vcr
and she's like
yeah i have a vcr she's like do you know
how much better texas chainsaw massacre
looks on vhs than on blue red
and i was like well at least they they
acknowledged that like why would you
have a [ __ ] vcr
in 2015 or whatever the second one was
made so i thought that was kind of funny
that they kind of
like homage like because i guess a lot
of people complained about why the [ __ ]
would anybody have a vcr in 2013 when
the first one came out
so she does the same thing where she
kind of goes
she sits around like watches all the
shorts and then at the end
like it turns out that you know whatever
the spirit of halloween or whatever like
comes and gets her
the interesting thing too is that all
hallows eve two
is much more halloween
themed like um it has like a much more
halloween
flavor to it like the first one the
wraparound is halloween
um the rest of them are just not really
um
but the second one like not all the
shorts take place on halloween
but there's like a lot more of them that
do and that are like
directly homaging halloween so i guess
it's kind of like more like a halloweeny
type movie than the first one
but they're two completely different i
mean the second one just looks like a
like um a really nicely made anthology
film and if it was called something else
you wouldn't even know that it had
anything to do with the first one
because there's like no continuity
between the two things
but that said it was like a decent movie
it was worth watching um
obviously some of the shorts are better
than the other ones uh some of them like
i said are super short and probably
could have been like expanded out a
little bit
whereas some of them were a little long
or like went on a little bit too long
tina showed up she's saying hi hey and
um let me see um
louie said that his friend in high
school had a great had a gremlin
i remember uh you remember the fourth
pino
[ __ ] one you rear-ended it would
catch on fire my mom had one of those
when i was a kid
yeah my brother had one yeah it was
powder blue my mom had like a 78 and
then later
i got i got a pinot story from
mississippi
later i guess this would have been late
80s early 90s it was before i
before i joined the army i ran into a
guy in mississippi that had a four-pitot
it turned into a [ __ ] dragster hot
rod made up out of junk i thought you
were gonna say it turned into something
else no
made out of junk is that an airplane a
boat
[Laughter]
it had like a 427 v8 motor if i can put
into the front end of it
and then a stiffer suspension because
all that weight
in the front and then he had the back
jacked up and big fat tires this is back
before it was cool to do this [ __ ]
because he just did it because he knew
how to do it and he had access to chuck
and why not that thing was a [ __ ]
screamer
it just sounded like a damn b-29 bomber
coming down the [ __ ] street
[Music]
he's [ __ ] bad ass he had to cut
he had to cut the interior wheel wells
out to get that big motor into the front
of that
in in front of that [ __ ] pinto
because it was weird is that ford cars
at that time all the
really they're still kind of modular you
can put anything out of anything in it
yeah had the axles from the trucks you
know and the ford trucks in the back of
it
yeah somebody at the door yeah hold on
let me see what's going on yeah somebody
yeah somebody asked uh if art the clown
was inspired by captain spalding
i'm not sure about that it's that's the
thing it's like killer clowns are so
ubiquitous nowadays
i do feel like art the clown kind of has
his own thing going because captain
spalding much like pennywise like kind
of had
his he was like a personality you know
what i mean like he talked and he was
funny and [ __ ] like that but also
murderous
whereas art the clown is just murderous
and seems to be enjoying himself
but doesn't really seem to have any
motive doesn't seem to have any
you know what i mean like because he
doesn't talk so it's all kind of like
body language
so i don't really know i have to say
that of all the killer clowns
that have come out because holy crap
there are so many [ __ ] killer clown
movies you guys it's like not even
was if if you're gonna make a horror
movie and i think we've talked about
this before
why would you make another killer clown
movie
why would you make another ouija board
movie why would you make another
demon possession maybe because you
couldn't think of anything else or you
just
like and i'm not saying that there
haven't been some new ones like demon
possession or whatever that have come
out that have been good because there
have
but it just seems like you're really
like shooting yourself in the dick if
you pick something that has
you know something that's had so many
movies made about it
so i think that's kind of like a
testament to
how iconic the art the clown character
became because even in a sea
of like so many killer clown movies he
still kind of stands out
you know what i mean so i will give it
that like he is a really really good
character and like i said if you see
terrifier
he's like really really good in that and
a lot of it is like face acting and like
you know body language stuff because he
doesn't ever say anything
and i think that that's one of the
things that makes him so scary
you know what i mean but uh yeah so like
i said these are both on tubie if you
don't
you know if you want to watch something
kind of halloweeny kind of gory
um you could certainly do a lot worse
like i said the first one is
it's a little yeah and like i said i
could have done without that alien story
you'll you'll see what i'm saying when
you see it i don't know why i had to be
an alien but whatever
but that's the thing i don't other than
the actual movie alien
i'm not a big fan of aliens as like bad
guys as like monsters you know what i
mean
i said because i'm more a horror person
i guess than a sci-fi person
so it's like whenever i see a movie and
they're like oh it's aliens i'm like uh
okay whatever so you know it's every now
and then i see one that's good but tammy
said her boyfriend in high school had a
green
[ __ ] pinto i think all the pintos the
green gremlin
grandma no okay yeah no they weren't
because my brother had one and i said it
was powder blue
yeah blue and green that's the only
colors i remember for the for the penta
i don't
i thought that was a brown one was there
a brown pinto
i feel like somebody i know like a
cousin or seven grandpa 70s would have
probably dictated that there would have
been a brown one well yeah because
everything was [ __ ] brown
orange and golden rhyme yeah but i don't
remember any red ones or orange ones and
i don't remember any white ones
i'm pretty sure there weren't any red
ones or white ones i don't remember ever
seeing those
70s american cars man they ford they
tried to go with the cheap
especially on the economy lines they
went for the cheapest paint they could
get
yeah and that was [ __ ] like [ __ ]
brown and green blue
isn't it weird to think of now because
it's like i can't think of that many
red cars from the 70s no my dad had one
it's because red paint was real
expensive in the city yeah
i can't remember what kind of car it was
cheap red paint on a car back in the 70s
the sun had [ __ ] burned it off in a
year
so they didn't go for that florida
anyway the only the only cars that
reliably had red were [ __ ] expensive
sports cars
like a ferrari yeah and they had this
expensive red paint that they used for
those
back in those days and uh you might be
able to find
the occasional uh corvette in red but
red just didn't last
i feel like most of the cars that i
remember from my childhood that like
family members owned and stuff were like
blue
green brown gold or cream
yeah i don't remember like white ones i
don't remember red ones
they didn't have silver i don't really
remember i don't remember we had some
silvery gray type
yeah i don't remember anyone i know
having silver ones though they were
mostly like
because the ford mach 3 was silver right
there because i remember my grandfather
had like a whole bunch of cadillacs
because he was a dude and he loved
cadillac's and his whole [ __ ]
backyard was full of them
and most of the almost all of them were
brown or gold you started seeing them
scar skylarks and [ __ ] and silver and
lebarons in that
in silver colors but it got real kind of
rough looking pretty quick yeah where it
didn't look metallic anymore it just
looked like gray sandpaper
oh yeah remember oh now that you
mentioned it my other grandfather
did have a gray car and like you said it
looked it wasn't shiny no
it was like a dog and it didn't it kind
of came like that yeah or it was shiny
like for a little while yeah it was real
low quality paint
yeah because they just didn't have the
polymers back then they didn't you know
it was all new technology
everything was it was like a lot so many
things were ugly it was uglier than you
think
and even like stuff like now when i see
movies that were made in the 70s i'm
like god that [ __ ] wallpaper and it's
like and i
i every time i see wallpaper from the
70s when i'm like i know at least one
person that had that wallpaper somewhere
in their house
70s and early 80s american cars were
particularly bad they were mass produced
and if you looked at how much they cost
they were
really cheap yeah they were they were
designed that you bought the thing
and then every two or three years you
traded it in for a new one they weren't
built to last
yeah you know it's changed a lot toyota
changed all that [ __ ]
yeah because they're like um why don't
we just make like good cars yeah
fall apart after you could get you could
get a toyota corolla sr5
spot five speed and it would it would it
was little
great gas mileage would run forever and
outrun
an american sports car yeah and it just
looked like a little damn box
just ugly i had one yeah today they were
today would be ugly but back in the day
they kind of looked futuristic in a way
well yeah and all you had to do is put
keep oil in it and [ __ ] change the
brake pads that [ __ ] ran forever
a few years ago i saw one on the road
somebody's still driving one
huh yeah it was like a i think there was
like a 87
or an 88 a [ __ ] toyota corolla sr5
the fastback the first car i ever had
was a 1987 toyota tercel
yeah it was a five speed yeah and in
fact that's what ended up that's what i
ended up having to trade it in because
the [ __ ] clutch kept going out
yeah all right uh
you done yeah i'm ready to go all right
so we will be
back tomorrow talking about yet another
newer halloween movie
uh which i've already watched so uh but
i'm not gonna tell you what it is
so uh we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow
and as usual thanks for stopping by bye